hello everybody hope they are good
Bitcoin made the move during the nation
session but not towards the week so the
trading setup failed okay remember that
in yesterday's video was saying that I
had a long open in this white box here
okay because I was expecting an aim
formation all the way to the 50 of this
week yeah okay uh you can see the price
they even get there okay so this is the
things about MW formation guys they are
not fixed patterns so they can be
irregular Peaks okay uh that was the
information here all right
um it doesn't have to be equal okay it
could even be higher why not uh in this
case you go here and then it dumped or
take profits didn't hit and or a stop
loss was hit here okay so what a shame
because uh the trading setup was
promising I don't regret even if it
didn't play out I think it was um it
made sense okay yesterday but
it doesn't matter
because now Bitcoin is making the move
okay
um the idea that I had yesterday is that
this white box here uh was a strong
support so in the moment that we lost
the support then we're gonna come and
fill this liquidity pool over here okay
um that's what happened during this
incision you can see here price doomed
very hard fill this liquidity pool and
today you're just going to the next one
so now the question is
is it gonna go to this one here below at
26 500 dollars or is it gonna have a
little bounce now that's what we're
going to try to figure it out now okay
because if you notice here in we're
going to the Daily time frame well now
sorry let's go back into the four round
let's stay there four hour time frame
um let me show you this we're talking
about this yesterday okay
let me remove all of this uh we were
saying that you know we had some kind of
um range in this one here okay let me
fix this a bit for you well we had this
range here we just fell back into the
range and if you notice here I was
telling you that one possibility was to
see an information or deviation
out of the range and then come back
inside okay
and I must tell you uh it looks like
that's what it played out and usually
when we see a deviation to the upside
then price breaks
below the range so pay attention to that
this reminds me to this price action let
me show you uh I remember it was around
48k I think it's here
you're gonna be able to see here pretty
well
um that's 48 I remember this trade very
very clear
um so if we have you know or range here
okay
um
something like this all right you can
see that we had here something quite
similar we had orange here
you can see uh low or high or it is the
low would it is the high and then we
break above it but it's only a deviation
just to break again below and then you
can see the price dumped quite a lot and
in this soon here
if you pay attention
this is an information too
um so why not are we seeing the same
pattern playing out
makes you think right it makes you think
for sure because we could be seeing the
same
but in the folder time frame and that
would make this a deviation or maybe now
we break low again okay so keep an eye
in mind guys but our care now it's in
short term
in lower time frame you can see that we
are filling this week over here if we
Mark the sessions we can see that
AC are doomed let me Mark them all okay
so uh uh industry sensation then London
held in this Zone here
okay
um what's in the typical pattern that is
this could be a stop hunt okay just to
fill maybe this liquidity pool
over here okay because that's another
imbalance in the chart the same as we're
feeling you know this one here sorry
this one here this one here this one
here we are we now have this one here
okay
so why not and if you notice the 50ma
we're a bit of an extended okay we are
600 well 500 dollars away from it so why
not I mean uh the New York session still
has a more than well around five hours
to run we started in New York session so
why not we can see
we could see something like this okay
maybe in all the way here sorry maybe
another way to the top of the liquidity
pool but at least to test the 50ma in
the one hour time frame so
um that's for now what I'm keeping an
eye on for today I would like to see
something like that okay I would like to
see some kind of Sword squeeze
um test the one hour 50ma and recover
some of this liquidity pool okay it's
true that everything looks easy and hand
side but uh I must admit a mistake I
made here okay I didn't check the order
book because if I check the order book
you can see that it was quite clear that
there was a lot of liquidity all the way
down to 27 300 okay check those red bars
over there so uh from now on uh I should
be paying more attention to the early
book because that was a very big clue
where in Hublot capital in the
liquidation levels and you can see that
the Delta here the cumulative
liquidation levels have reversed okay
and at this point there was seven and a
half billion dollars worth of long
liquidations okay cumulative uh right at
the peak uh now if you notice we have a
different story there are five
and a half billions worth of dollars of
short liquidations so it seems that the
next one is to pay the price might be
short okay that's why I'm telling you
that idea of a short squeeze should not
be dismissed now if you check at the
right of the screen okay you're gonna be
able to see this is spikes okay and
there is an interesting one right below
okay this pink Spike these are zones
with liquidations and if you check the
here it tells you that those are Longs
in times 25 leverage and that is a lot
of liquidation from those longs
at 26
700 so why not maybe we still see maybe
the stophunt is not finished okay we
might be able to see one more drop lower
hit those liquidations okay at 26 700
ish
and then maybe we see some kind of
reverse and that could be tomorrow
because tomorrow is Thursday okay and on
Thursdays you know that we usually see
some kind of reversal so if you notice
here okay 26 700 that's quite
interesting soon and to the upside we
have uh let me zoom in because you want
to be able to see this better
and to the upside we have
27 300 that's another spec here twenty
seven thousand five hundred
psychological number twenty seven
thousand seven hundred fifty
twenty seven thousand nine hundred and
of course 20 330 and that will be the
fifty percent of the week so I'm telling
you guys I'm still not dismissing the
idea of the Wakefield strategy okay
um I think that the chances are
just by looking at this chart okay the
chances are in my opinion the price goes
to twenty six thousand seven hundred
first okay hit those liquidations here
this is Spike of liquidity and maybe
tomorrow
we can see a midweek reversal
how high well the 50 main one or time
frame that's your first Target and also
for targets I'm gonna use these spikes
of liquidity okay now if we go into the
liquidation heat map let's see if we can
visualize this in a different way what
the chart says okay 12 hours time frame
let's see if we see something clear
um okay we see that there is a lot of
liquidity at 27
475 that's quite interesting and also if
you notice here there is quite of
liquidity between 26 750 and 26 625 so
that's what I mean guys why not maybe we
still have to create race this Zone here
okay between 26 700 and 26 600.
before we can see some kind of reversal
to watch this on here in the chart okay
okay now seven days time frame let's
check this
let's see how it's looking
let's get this Zone over here uh I mean
in here you can see too 26 700 26 650
that's the closest liquidation Zone okay
so uh now you can see how we're putting
it all together but it seems quite
likely that the stop Hunt is not fantasy
okay and that they still have to recover
this Zone at least okay and then from
here yes we can try to figure it out if
you can see a midweek reversal tomorrow
most likely I'm saying tomorrow because
it usually happens on Thursdays
sometimes it happens on Wednesdays but
thinking that they still have some work
to do at distance here uh most likely
thing is that there is not enough time
today
um potentially if we see a reversely
should be tomorrow and not today okay
um in higher time frame let's go to the
monthly time frame
um the chart doesn't tell so smooth okay
uh yesterday knows uh well we'll point
out that this liquidation Zone here 2700
they filled it and went uh koala above
it to be honest to 28 400.
um it seems that it's retracing from
there but if you check the chart at
least in the one month time frame there
is more liquidity to the upside than to
the downside okay
uh so that's quite interesting that in
the short term
the liquidity seems to be to the upside
well if we go to the three months time
frame
don't want to be able to see that the
story here is different let me get all
this done because this is very
interesting you have here 25 400.
billion dollars worth of liquidations
that's insane and a bit lower we have 22
600 22 400 this one hasn't moved for
quite some time so let's see how it
reacts when price is approaching I mean
this one here 25 400 you can see very
clearly how the liquidity has increased
as we've been you know touching this
Zone 2500 you can see okay that's very
normal that's because the retail Traders
are gonna you know go long
when price is going up so the
liquidations are gonna be here so I mean
in a way it would make sense what I've
told you you know you have the range
information of deviation and then you
break below again uh in that way it
makes sense so if we go back to the chat
with the information you can see that
let's maritas on 26
726 600 okay so in this one here
between 26700 and 26 600 there are a lot
of liquidations okay so why not we could
imagine
the price is not finished in this Zone
and it can still go to this yellow box
here hit those liquidations and then
tomorrow we could see the midweek
reversal towards the 50ma in the water
time frame if you notice
it looks that it's a bit overextended so
what do I want to see ideally ideally I
would like to see price uh could
consolidate here let me remove this a
second you could consolidate here in
this Asian session okay
but ideally
what I would like to say is a drop you
know go to this Zone then in this one I
probably try to go again into Longs okay
hopefully it's not a fake idea like it
was in this Zone over here okay and then
from here I'm expecting tomorrow to see
some kind of recovery towards the 50ma
in the one hour time frame okay so
that's the plan I have for now and some
of you will be wondering what about the
week is that week
invalidated I mean in the short term yes
because we're going to be looking for a
projection like this okay but of course
that imbalance in the four hour time
frame that week to the in the highs here
this is still a very interesting Zone
that I'm not going to remove from the
chart okay that's on here that week is
still a very important week because we
are talking about a 400 a week that's
quite a lot and price should come back
to this Zone sooner or later okay go
back to the chart one hour time frame
and something very interesting is uh
that you can see very clearly here is
how to use the 50ma okay if you check
this one here
okay and if you take this one here
it's exactly the same let me remove all
of this quick lesson this Zone here and
this one is exactly the same why because
you are in this Zone okay in this one
over here you are below the 1 hour 50ma
you know you can see here it's
resistance you're hitting your head
hitting your head you cannot go above it
but when that happens and you don't see
a quick drop
so what you are expecting here is to see
a breakup of it support
and then continuation to the upside same
here okay you can see the same here you
are coming here and you are testing as a
support support support
but you can't bounce hard okay you
cannot bounce towards the week there's
something that I should be paying
attention in the Asian session last
night okay before I went to bed because
well I saw this
I should have matched this to what I saw
here because it's exactly the same okay
then in this one here
you can see the price breaks below the
15 minute one hour time frame tested as
a resistance you can see here very well
okay so it does this and then it
continues going lower it's so simple so
guys remember this pattern because you
wanna see this playing often it's very
simple
um it's one indicator that you can use
for Confluence in the chart and it's so
easy to use so guys that's pretty much
all
um Bitcoin and utilities plan didn't
work out the wick is still there it
hasn't gone anywhere so that's still an
interesting Zone but it's quite far at
the moment so we are not gonna be paying
too much attention to it we go level by
level and at the moment we are looking
at this one over here dies between 26
700 or 26 600 there is some liquidity
there grab the liquidity and maybe
tomorrow we can see a midweek reversal
towards the 50 May in the one hour time
frame okay so that would be a nice
straight these are around uh 600 move
maybe we can catch that tomorrow okay
that's what I'm gonna try to pay
attention to so guys thank you so much
for watching
and I'll see you soon